today we have a super special guest I am
so delighted that we have Chip Heath
here
for many years and I am a big fan of his
work he's written extensively about
human behavior in the context of
organizations he's a professor at the
Business School right across campus and
he's a co-author with his brother of
several really interesting books what is
called decisive how to make better
decisions in life and work switch how to
change things when change is hard
made to stick why some ideas survive and
others don't and his newest book the
power of moments I've tell you that I
love this book
I got an early copy of it and I started
to read the end and couldn't put it down
I think this is honestly I think one of
the most important books they've written
thank you yeah I want to suggest John
Grisham though well I really loved it
and I thought it was really important so
I'd love to know what motivated you to
write this book with your brother so so
Dan and I are 10 years apart this has
been kind of a family bonding experience
for us to work together and so we get
together at mom and dad's house
typically when we're working on a book
and we had tried a couple of other
concepts that weren't working very well
and any one point Dan said what does it
mean when people say that their there
was a defining moment a defining moment
in life of defining moment of career and
we started exploring that and pretty
quickly we became fascinated with this
idea so sometimes in our life or more
impactful than others and so you know
there are certain moments in a vacation
that stand out in the vacation but
they're also certain moments in your
university career that stand out and it
turns out if we asked you five years
from now or 10 years from now those of
you that are still undergraduates what
do you remember from your college career
40% of your memories would come from the
first six weeks of freshman year that's
what studies show and why is that an
impactful time listen first time you're
on your own the first time you're doing
things by yourself you're you're going
out to a party and nobody's checking up
on you when you come home
people remember graduation but junior
year is like a black hole of a memory
there's nobody nobody remembers anything
from junior year so juniors work on that
you know tried to do something that is
memorable maybe that's a good argument
for studying overseas and and so it car
tests that some things stick with us and
some things don't some
things matter why don't we take more
control of that and what could we do and
as a business to create defining moments
for customers or for ourselves and our
families I love the fact that you use an
acronym and then in the book you kind of
throw it out because you think it's a
little bit gimmicky but I love the
acronym because it really helped me the
acronym is epic for elevation insight
pride and connection can you talk about
this because I think what you're trying
to get it is that there are certain
moments in our life where we are primed
to have a defining moment and that one
can leverage that to actually make them
even more valuable yeah so so what we
what we found after asking lots of
people for what are the moments that
mattered to you most in your career or
what are the moments that matter to you
most as a family or what were the
moments from your last vacation is stood
out there were certain things that came
up over and over again and so that's
where epic come from and we don't like
that because not all of the moments that
we're talking about in the framework
have to be epic
and we can't resist hearing that surfer
dude you know saying epic but that's the
spring right elevation is moments of
sensory experience and so if you've ever
stood in National Park and seeing the
beautiful views that's a that's a moment
of elevation if you've ever seen a
fireworks show if you've if you've
enjoyed a favorite food I mean birthday
cupcakes or the classic distillation of
sensory experience you've got sugar fat
and flame one little compact object EP
pride
so moments of pride or moments when we
set out to achieve something and we
actually achieve it and in in the moment
when somebody recognizes you for that so
certain certain professions like
military people are smart enough to wear
uniforms that signal their pride in
their position they have a chest full of
medals that show you the experiences and
the skills that they've acquired that's
a source of pride but basically whenever
somebody says you know I saw what you
didn't really appreciate it that that's
the moment of pride and those two stick
out in their mind insight moments of
insight are not always pleasurable
that's one of the mistake I think that
we make in talking about consumer
experiences is that they all have to be
delightful there are lots of moments of
insight there there are Ohno moments you
know and and so we may decide this is
not the job for us or or I've stretched
myself too far on this project but
moments of insight are powerful
because they tell you something
different than you can do for your life
or your business or your the plate of
the game that you're playing and so
those moments are important and then
finally connection and these are the
most profound moments in life the
moments with our families with our
friends with work colleagues and so
feeling that that bridge that connection
with another person is is tremendously
valuable so this is that mantra profile
your lecture series and of course your a
thought leader but a lot of these folks
in the audience are hoping to be thought
leaders in the future leading
organizations leading teams why is it
important for someone in a leadership
position to understand this I mean is
this just about birthday cake and
candles or why in an organization should
I be worried about defining moments well
I think there are certain you're certain
moments when you can make a big impact
on your employees or on your customers
and these are the tools that you have
available to you so one of the stories I
love from the book is john deere classic
american come in to make tractors and in
this country a lot of people know of
john deere because we're only most of us
are only a couple of generations from
people that actually farm the the ground
but it is your inner china in india
there's not that history there not that
connection and so they they took
something that is an important moment of
life but we typically don't honor it
much it's the first day on the job and I
don't know about you and your last job
but the typical experience I think of
the first day on the job is you show up
and the person the reception desk is
really happy to see you but they
actually thought you were coming in
early next week you know and and so
somebody will stop by and in in rescue
you and take you to your cubicle which
is the monitors there but the cpu unit
isn't hooked up and and the person is
like for a meeting and so they kind of
drop you off and they grab for an
employee manual that's sitting in the in
the cubicle room the last owner and say
well here why don't you look through
this for a while so you spend your
morning reading expense reimbursement
policy and an assorted other technical
things finally somebody right before
lunch takes pity on you and whisk you
around the office to meet 23 people who
are themselves late for a meeting or
late for lunch and so you feel a little
guilty for interrupting them it's not an
optimal experience is the first day and
so what john deere did is they said
let's let's design this so that it makes
an impact on people and you only have
one first day on you
so what it is they assigned everybody
texting buddy and so you've been texting
back and forth of this person and and
they tell you what we're we're - how to
get to the location they tell you how to
dress for the first day but they show up
in they hand you your favorite beverage
so common latte or the chai latte or you
know whatever it is that you've been
talking about because they work that
into the text message on the monitors on
the front wall have your name on it
say welcome you know chip Heath and and
as the person takes you to your cubicle
there's a banner this stretches up a
little bit above the cubicle farm a
couple of feet above and so people can
look across and see that there are new
people on the floor and then stop by at
their leisure during the day your first
the monitor is set up is hooked up and
it's showing beautiful pictures of
screenshots of tractors and you wouldn't
think that there are Beauty shots
attractive you get a tractor out in the
sunset and plowing the last few rows
before the evening and it's it's a
beautiful thing and it's scrolling by
and you you you click the screensaver
off and your first email is there from
the CEO of John Deere and he appears in
a little video and he talks about 175
year history of this company this was a
company that was founded by John Deere
he had a patent for a plow that looks
pretty innocuous but it was a plow of it
that was less likely to follow up with
roots as you're plowing the ground and
if we're on the side of the desk there's
actually a little toy model of the plow
and so you look at this thing as a
hundred seven figures ago John Deere got
a patent on this because he saved
farmers time and allowed them to plow
more and the CEO talks about the fact
that this is a company that's devoted to
helping the world have more food and
more shelter those are two needs that we
desperately need and so he says welcome
to the most important work you'll ever
do and you know we hope you'll have a
long history with John Deere your
manager stops by right before lunch and
says you know I'd love to have lunch
with you tomorrow but today I'd like you
to go up to lunch with a few of your
peers and so you meet up with four or
five of your peers at lunch they talk
about the projects that they're working
on why they think they're important and
so you think about the end of that day
we elevation sensory experience if it's
not a lot there but you got your
favorite beverage in the morning you get
the muddle the plow that you can pick up
and hold in your hand you've got the
beautiful shots of tractor
a lot more on pride and insight I mean
you may not have known the history 175
year history of this company you may not
have thought about the fact that I'm
doing work document product because I'm
helping people eat I'm helping people
have shelter over their heads and
connection is just off the charts you'll
get your texting buddy you've got the
people that you meet at lunch you've got
a first email from the CEO and that's a
good first day and in fact the reaction
was a lot of people that had been in the
company before they started this program
it's like can I quit so I can go back I
have that is my first day now my
question to all of us is why isn't every
first day kind of like that and I don't
know I don't know how we could how could
we do it orientation for four freshmen
but you know was your freshman
orientation like that even if it was was
your first orientation towards your
major because at some point you declare
a major and was that as good an overview
of the major was it as motivating for
you know inspiring you to what kind of
careers you could aspire to with a math
degree or an electrical engineering
degree or whatever it is there there are
only a few opportunities that we have
like that in life why aren't we seizing
all of them you know most people have
710 jobs in lyon fit so well i'd love
that story and I think I know Stanford
does a big deal with the first day of
school I know that they they spent a
lotta time designing that experience but
that's been the first day how often do
you need to have these to keep you
motivated I mean is it something you
should do something every month you know
a milestone every year I'm gonna guess
that this is you know after the first
day if a year later you haven't had any
more of these defining moments it's sort
of dwindles in impact yeah and I think
the answer for that is there's there's
room for more and and I don't know what
the bright limit is because I don't
think anybody's pushing that limit and
so you know think about projects that we
have do we do we always take the time to
celebrate you know the end of a project
and acknowledge you know well we did a
good job on that or here's what we could
have learned from that so looking for
moments of insight are looking for
moments of connection with people at the
beginning of project we don't always
take the time to have dinner with people
that were about to work with an exchange
story is it you know
what what we liked and didn't like about
previous projects so I think there are
small ways in large ways john deere
first day orientation is a big way but
if you're if you're celebrating a
project that failed you know why not
have why not have a miniature wake for
the project and you know drink beers and
tell stories about you know the the work
that you put in you know in celebrated
we actually had a fabulous talk here if
maybe some people have seen it where
Astro teller was here talking about at
Google X the process they go through
when they end a project it's quite
dramatic so you might want to find out
that story it's a great great example of
creating quite an experience around
ending a project I think it's also
interesting about the little tiny things
that you describe they can be done my
favourite example and I'm sure that
other people remember it also from the
book is about the popsicle phone can you
talk about that because as a customer
often there are things that you can do
that dramatically change your experience
with a company with one little tiny
thing that they did to really surprise
you yeah at the time we were writing the
book there there there was a hotel that
ranked in Trip Advisor's top three
hotels of Los Angeles and it's called
the Magic Castle Hotel now the number
one hotel is the hotel bel-air which is
a Hollywood boutique hotel their massive
pool that has its own weather system in
it so far their the the rooms have
bespoke wood furniture high thread-count
sheets you can control everything in the
room the drapes the $3,000 stereo system
with an iPad controller the floor is
heated which is absolutely critical in
those terrible horrific Hollywood
winters so that's that's the hotel Bel
Air the number three is the Four Seasons
and what's not in the top three as is
the W the Ritz you know all kinds of
brands that have their own Los Angeles
hotel number two there's Magic Castle
Hotel you look at it and it looks
suspiciously like a 1960s apartment
building because it is a 1960s apartment
building in canary-yellow the pool
there's nowhere near the size of the
Hotel bel-air the rooms are not
particularly mean it's more IKEA than
bespoke
furniture there is there is a controller
that you can use to control the lights
and the drapes you say to your child
honey could you get up and get
voice-activated works but the Magic
Castle Hotel is is not nearly the
physical plant that you would expect
from a number-two hotel but what what is
true is that if you go to the snack bar
right in your room there's a long list
of things you can order from the front
office and it has it has Kit Kats it has
Cracker Jacks as grape soda it has cream
soda it has much longer about 30 things
that are available all for free and if
you've ever had the mistake made the
mistake of eating having that salt
craving at night and having the cashews
you know and realizing you wasted a
sixth of your tuition for that quarter
this this is a very different experience
but the thing that people always remark
on is by the pool there's a phone red
phone looks like a cold war-era relic
you know the President of the United
States could use to call the premier of
the Soviet Union and if you walk over
and pick up the red phone well above the
red phone is this saying sign pin it
says popsicle hot line and so you walk
over and you pick up the red phone and a
voice on the other end says we'll be
right out and a few minutes later if
somebody walks out of the front office
with white gloves carrying a silver tray
and they pass popsicles around the pool
and the kids are beaming the adults are
beaming there's no better recipe for
happiness than a cold popsicle and warm
Los Angeles afternoon and what's
remarkable about that and what's
remarkable the snack foods is for less
than the hotel Bel Air spins on chlorine
tablets for their massive pool they are
creating happiness and they do it
reliably and systematically if you check
in to the Magic Castle hotel the desk
clerk is trying to ask you you know is
there a special event that you're
celebrating here and a case of people
say oh we're here for Jon's birthday
well in the back there's a person who's
eavesdropping and if they say something
like you're celebrating Jon's birthday
there are a set of cakes in the back and
some cake decorating equipment and so
they quickly scroll happy birthday John
they grab some of the balloons that are
already inflated there and they they
practice this that
did you do - rune dashes you know
practice getting to the room with the
cake and the balloons without spilling
anything you walk into the room you know
and the couple that has just introduced
themselves five minutes earlier to the
front desk they walk in in their
balloons there there's a cake that says
happy birthday John and they go how did
they do that that's magic
that's magic and that's what they're
going for those wow moments and the
amazing thing is once you see what
they're doing is so easy and yet I walk
in I walk into hotels all the time and
the Hilton in the Marriott in San
Francisco looks just like the one in New
Orleans it looks like just like the one
in Austin why don't we walk into every
hotel room and there's a drink in a
snack that exemplifies local cuisine
that you'll know and get there I mean
why wouldn't why shouldn't we have a
sense of place about things and and so
the Magic Castle is doing stunning work
very inexpensively just by thinking
about moments of elevation I love it I
mean I think those are things we can do
every day we can do for our friends and
family right so can you do it for
yourself can you decide to create your
own defining moments or does someone
else have to do it for you I think if if
you're not creating your defining
moments you're you're missing
opportunities and especially in graduate
school you know the ability that you
have to meet interesting people on a
university campus like this that ought
to be a source of lots of defining
moments the time that we take with
friends and this is not easy right this
because it's hard to coordinate
schedules especially with the busy
people you're right but if you don't if
you don't take a road trip with friends
every once in awhile and do something
unusual you're you're not taking
advantage of the time that you have in
graduate school and so you know go see
the Northern Lights go go to Iceland and
stay in an ice castle you know and you
may think I don't have enough money to
do this but your credit cards are
already highly leveraged and what
finance professors will tell you is that
there's this life cycle of income that
says you all are gonna make be making
good salaries in a few years the amount
that you have on your credit cards now
you're gonna be able to pay it off
eventually so charge extra I'll keep
that in mind business school professor
just gave you permission
I'm thinking going back to organisations
I mean I love that I'm gonna start
defining trading some more moments in my
life but let's say you know you're
running an organization should you
actually have a chief experience officer
you know somebody you know we're now
starting to get you know people who have
roles who look at the business from
different perspectives whether it's
security or innovation should be there
as chief defining moments officer I I
think the chief HR officer ought to be a
chief experience officer because your
employees deserve moments in their
careers that are celebrated and rewarded
I mean when people become managers
there's a big shift that you make from
being an individual contributor to
working through others and so we have
the whistle the coach whistle award that
is given to people it says this is the
moment which I shift from being on the
field to being off the field in helping
others achieve in their career so the
chief human resource officer I would be
chief experience officer chief financial
officer ought to be chief experience
officer because the amount available we
could have study in the book for every
person that you can move from neutral
about your product to a 10 out of 10
really positive fan your nine dollars
for that person for every person you
move from dissatisfied to neutral if you
could solve all the problems you durn
one buck as opposed to nine dollars for
making the neutral people more satisfied
chief financial officer if they want to
be serious about revenues I ought to be
thinking about living all the people
that are whelmed by the project neutral
about the product all the way up to
raving fans chief operating officer are
you thinking about routines for this but
look the CEO the chief experience
officer ought to be the CEO the chief
executive officer because that's what
your organization is delivering in no
matter what what domain you're in you're
delivering experiences to your customers
or clients and that that shouldn't be a
separated audience so I'm gonna get the
chief experience officer
but the point is we all should be yeah I
mean I think that's the point is that we
all should be looking at that everything
we're doing each day saying how could I
optimize this experience for myself for
my team for my customers are there some
things that can't be optimized some
experiences that you you know what we
just got to write that off or can ever
thing be I I like to run the thought and
I'm an author and I've been thinking
about experiences so of course I'm gonna
believe that everything can be optimized
but let's take a stake one of the the
most basic moments that we have in our
culture which is happy birthday parties
right we do a pretty good job of those
we we've got elevation we've got the
cupcakes there we have music there we
sing songs to people we bring together
their friends and family to celebrate
the birthday but imagine if you added
one or two other elements of the
framework to that moment so inside how
would you get inside it in your birthday
suppose you had filled out every year of
your life on your birthday a little note
to yourself about what you learned that
year I I think it would be fascinating
to go back and look at what did my
eight-year-old self say was the most
important thing I learned that year or
what did my 25 year old self I shudder
to think you know what what I would look
have learned some of those years but I
think that would be a moment that would
make a birthday more meaningful time
capsules if you're a parent some parents
are smart enough to mark the height of
their kids on the door sill so you can
see how much you've grown in the last
year well if you had a time capsule for
your kids that you put together every
year that had a math homework and a list
of their friends and the list of the
shows that they used to watch and they
could look back two years and say that
math is so easy and I was still watching
my little pony can you grown so so I
think if if we took some of these
principles and built them in to even
good events we might have potential for
creating any better events great so in a
couple minutes I'm going to open up for
questions so you can start thinking of
your burning questions so um when you
create defining moments some of these
things are making you more comfortable
some of them but some of them make you
uncomfortable right they they get you
out of your comfort zone and you're
doing something different is there a
trade-off between sort of feeling alive
and feeling comfortable though is a
significant part of creating defining
moments sort of just getting you off
your to find path I think that's that's
part of it so doing something novel is
always it's always good to to make
something memorable and remarkable and
and also like the insight that it's
always positive moments so so one of the
most popular courses at Harvard is
actually run another career counseling
center and one of the things that they
do with audiences like you and
especially those of you that want to be
entrepreneurs is they say what are your
goals for the next five ten years and
everybody writes down their goals and
then they have this exercise where they
say okay take out your take out your
your calendar your your phone you know
whatever whatever mechanism you use to
keep it counted look at the last two
weeks shade in the times during those
last two weeks when you're pursuing that
five-year tenure goal and people do that
exercise and it's like oh no you know
it's like I had nothing in the last two
weeks pursuing that five-year goal
that's not a positive delight moment of
delight but it is a profound moment
because we realized that how little
unless we take time how little we were
pursuing the goals that we say that we
want to pursue in the course of a normal
existence and so so I think defining
moments or moments that change our
trajectory and in move us towards
goodness that they're not always
positive because I'm thinking when I was
reading the book I was thinking of
experience I had being in Paris and
being on a the ferris wheel the big
ferris wheel in Paris and getting stuck
at the top in the middle of a lightning
storm that was a defining moment so I
I'm gonna guess how many people in the
room have had like been on a vacation
the most memorable experience was
something where you had a flat tire or
you know you'll got lost or you remnant
lost your wallet I mean these are these
are moments you remember and recount to
people so often those moments are ones
that you might not want to relive but
there were ones that are very memorable
yeah and I think I think especially you
know the military knows this for sure
because boot camp is filled with
negative moments that bond you with
other people that they're going through
them at the same time and and so a lot
of a lot of if you're a manager and
you're in charge of a group in the
future taking the time to celebrate
those miserable times that you spent
together doing the last crunch for a
deadline or the late nights those are
the source of those are the sorts of
stories that are going to bond you to
your college well you know it's
interesting I always in my classes on
the team projects I always make them do
at 9:00 in the morning as opposed to
9:00 the prior
because it means that the more likely
the teams are going to stay up all night
doing it and of course they could have
done it at 9:00 at night and been done
and submitted it but most work all night
getting it done and that changes
dramatically their experience of the
project because they did something that
felt really hard together
yeah and it's good preparation for life
in Silicon Valley it was just a little a
little tweak to change their
relationship with the project so let's
see first question from the audience
who's got something yes so the question
is we shifting the economy from what was
it products good services and now
experiences in the question what's next
after experiences if you'll forgive me
because I just finished a book on
experiences and published it last fall
I'm not quite ready for experiences to
be done yet and I think there's a long
way to go on experiences I mean we we
are not celebrating we are not making
moments of most of the things that we
should make so you don't get a note from
the bank when you paid down half your
mortgage saying congratulations you've
paid down half your mortgage teachers in
classrooms in elementary school are
probably not celebrating the five
hundredth book read by their class in in
the school year right there are lots of
opportunities for experiences that we're
not taking advantage of so I haven't
thought about what's next I love the
question but we have some work to do an
experiences first are there ways to make
bad experiences less memorable I mean
let's say somebody's going into the
hospital and you know having some some
terrible thing happened to them yeah um
you know and they really want to make it
less of a defining moment I think it's a
great question and it's one that we we
largely punted on in the book because we
don't want a systemic
to create bad experiences for people but
there is some there are some hints and
there's a very interesting literature
you've heard of post-traumatic stress
but there is an interesting literature
that has studied people that have had
awful things happen to them you know
health problems or natural disasters or
are accidents and had rebounded from
that and it's called post-traumatic
growth and the post-traumatic growth
literature if you read it through the
lens of what makes defining moments is
interesting because for example they'll
say that one thing I learned in the
hospital while I was struggling with
cancer radiation and chemotherapy is
that the small comforts the small
pleasures were really meaningful yeah so
a dessert that somebody brought me that
tasted good or the hot towels that the
nurses would bring around the night that
smelled like lavender
you know those are moments little
sensory experiences in the midst of that
Hospital experience are powerful for
people and I don't know if they're I
don't know if they're dietitians at
hospitals but I think the last time you
need a dietitian involved in the thing
is hospitals because what you ought to
feed people is ice cream cheese you know
whatever feels good chocolate is
wonderful but if you listen to people
who have gone through those
post-traumatic growth they say
connection is really important that I
learned through my friends and people I
could count on really were bit moments
of pride from from achieving a course of
treatment so so I think some of the same
principles would help us get through
even bad events but we don't talk about
that a lot in the book that's a really
really interesting insight do we have
another question yes question but the
comment I think some hospitals have seen
now they're over like spirituality and
meditation but to a question of
you should keep yourself in the realm of
experiences and not wanting to rule next
thing in experiences do you think of
like different experiences that are
coming up now classifications there are
things are changing types of experiences
so the question is are there changing
types of experiences I think I've got a
vote for what needs to change and I
think it's relates to the conversations
we had earlier about you know all are
all experiences all the funny moments
positive we've spent a lot of time in
consumer experiences talking about
moments of delight so that's the Magic
Castle
you know the popsicle hot line the the
free snacks from the snack bar but I
think moments of insight and especially
in b2b context are very powerful so an
interesting book came out a couple of
years ago called the Challenger sale and
we typically think of salespeople as
managing a relationship so they're there
for you they're there 24/7 they're
responsive and there are important
subset of salespeople that are rated to
score high on that dimension of just
service orientation but the sales people
that are most valued by companies that
the CEO of the company says this was
this was the most meaningful sales
relationship I had or actually what they
call challenger salespeople and
challenger salespeople are not therefore
you have 24/7 you know helping you with
service they're they're challenging you
and your picture of your business in
your picture of your industry and what
what the ratings say is that these
challenger salespeople were highly
valued by customers and clients they say
it's because they changed the way that I
thought about my business I thought I
was doing this but they pointed out that
I'm also doing that and I needed some
tools additional tools for doing that
they showed me some things about the
industry that hadn't known before and so
being able to bring that moment of
insight even if that insight is
sometimes painful for people who are
receiving it that's a very valued thing
and I think that's that's a place I
would push us is think about what are
the what are the experiences that matter
in all forms all emotions you know so
what experience connection what are the
experiences that lead to loyalty it's
not clear that those are always the
positive emotion experiences they're
their sensation the people caring for us
and so my favorite example that is why
why should I log on to Yelp every time
so I'm a foodie and every time I'm in a
new town I open up yell and I search for
restaurants and every time I have to
take their sword
which is some combination of value plus
distance plus advertising revenues or
whatever it is
and and say I want it sorted by rating
because I'm willing to drive an extra
mile to eat the finest burrito or the
best Pad Thai in a city I have never
once even though I'm from Texas I've
never once clicked on a steak place and
so why in every every town
do I have to ignore ten steak places
that show up in the top rankings because
I'm never gonna click on that our
technology we spend a lot of time
talking about machine learning and
artificial intelligence in big data
there are patterns of behavior that we
have with our technology they're not
being picked up even though we do them
every single time every single time
allowing to expedia I have to tell it I
don't want to see the one-leg flights
that one stop flies I wanna see the
nonstop flights and by the way they
hopefully on that first ranking they
show you the two plus stop flights who
takes those travel masochists you know
that we want to stop in lots of places
on the way to creating experiences on
the creating experiences like walking up
and down that jet jet bridge is really
exciting so why should I have to tell
Yelp or Expedia every time nonstop
flights and sort them by departure time
as opposed to by price you know that's
why is that technology could benefit
from us and all those are ways of
establishing connection that I
understand you I'm caring for you it's
not a big a ha Wow moment of delight
like the popsicle hot line this is a
constant reliable thing that technology
is either doing or not doing to tell us
we're understood and we're valued so
this begs the question though how do you
know which experiences to amplify to
optimize you know we have a thousand
experience through the day you know you
get up you brush your teeth you take a
shower you have breakfast do you
exercise you commute to work I mean
they're an infinite number of things
that happen how do you choose which ones
whether it's your work or your personal
life that you know you know this is the
one that I should really focus on I
don't know I don't know the answer to
that question in general but but what
I've challenged you to do is to spend
time experimenting and luckily there's
so much room to experiment that
they think you're gonna hit something
pretty quick and so for example when we
talk to companies about how much time
they spend solving problems fixing
problems as opposed to creating upside
experiences the typical ratio the median
in the mode is to say we spend 80% of
our time fixing problems and 20% of our
time thinking about upside if your
company is only spent twenty percent of
its time thinking about upside there are
lots of opportunities pick one pick two
and start experimenting and I think what
you'll see is there should be a very
fast feedback cycle because when you get
when you get one of these moments like
the the popsicle hot line you're gonna
see such a dramatic change in the
customers reactions that you'll you'll
you'll know very quickly if you're on to
something yeah I think of an experience
that I had that dramatically affected me
and I'm wonder if you've seen this I've
actually now seen in a few other places
where a restaurant you get to the end of
the meal and they give you a little you
know bag of granola or the little muffin
for breakfast and you go wow like
they've just created something that
costs practically nothing that I know
the next morning I'm gonna get up and
have you know the meal essentially
continued that's beautiful yeah and
you're thinking back to the restaurant
to prove exactly yeah I think we we miss
all kinds of opportunities with that I
mean why why doesn't every restaurant
present you with a little amuse-bouche
taste you know whatever the restaurant
is and I've done that going to
restaurants a couple of times and that
happens and you just feel warmly about
that restaurant from the very start of
the meal just because they brought you a
little a little bit by appetizers yeah
yeah something a question right here
last part of your question again so Mary
I guess the question is you're thinking
that maybe we've lost our ability and we
need to sort of amplify what we're doing
because people in their everyday life
are not experiencing things fully yeah I
think what our what our brains are
designed to do is to highlight pools of
opportunity and pools of pain right and
so what we tend to remember from any
experience we remember beginnings and
ends
because transitions seem to be important
for for organisms maybe moving from one
environment to the other
and remember highlights but a lot of the
stuff in the middle tends to wash away
and so for example I rode Space Mountain
at Disney World for the first time when
I was in college and what I know from
the records that they keep is that the
average wait time for Space Mountain is
60 minutes and Space Mountain to my
surprise was not the 10 minute right
well I think so I thought it was
probably 5 minutes it's actually two and
a half minutes right but this is one of
the best roller coasters in the world
because not only is a good roller
coaster in and of itself but they put it
inside a dome and it's completely black
and so when you take off in the
roller-coaster they have the the you're
going into space and you launch out and
you're dodging asteroids and zooming by
the rings of Saturn and I thought it was
one of the best things I'd ever done now
in retrospect I don't remember an hour
of weight which is kind of remarkable
because that was a painful hour I hate
waiting in those queues is on a
ten-point scale it's probably a three so
it's it's below neutral but it's not
awful you know you can do it but what I
remember is that 10 out of 10 two and a
half minutes then in my mind had
expanded to four or five minutes right
and I think that's one of the paradoxes
that Disney understands that most of us
don't understand is that our brains are
wired to think about highlights and in
pits it's not where to think about all
the emotions in the middle and so the
paradox of Disney is that most times if
you're if you ping people at a random
time during the day it isn't wrong most
of the time they're probably less happy
than they would have been sitting on
their couch at home because Disney World
is in it mean it was built on swamp it's
90 degrees it's 90 percent humidity you
know there was no wonder that Walt
Disney when he looked around for fifty
one continuous square miles found land
at Disney World because is a swamp and
so it's not structurally designed for
people as a vacation spot but it is a
set of people that think seriously about
peak experiences and so even if we're
kind of vaguely miserable
of the day there are those peak moments
that make it one of the best experiences
that we and our family have had I'm
reminded of you know some period of my
life where I have a lot of learning
experiences you know a lot of defining
moments I said these are all character
building and I kept thinking okay I have
enough character can we stop yeah you
know can you get to a point where you're
just having too many defining moments
yeah yeah and I think they're they're
stress stress indices that say
especially if you're defining moments or
of the hive I made a mistake we can we
can satiate them those yeah so dude said
so let me ask you can you have an
organization so focused on this that it
actually becomes a decrease there
becomes decreased efficiency can you get
can an organization have too many
defining moments I think I think it
could but but again what I want to what
I want to argue is it were so far from
that perspective you know ask people ask
people have as your organization
celebrated you enough shown a sufficient
gratitude for all the work that you put
in and 80% of the people in in the world
employees say you know my manager
doesn't recognize my performance very
often and 80% of managers say I'm
recognizing performance all the time
right I'm constantly showing gratitude
towards people's performance and so
there's this gap between what the
organization thinks it's doing and what
the employees think the organization is
doing and I think anything we can do to
bring that together is a good thing
great
do you have another question yes back
here oh when he was the head football
coach of Notre Dame Lou Holtz was asked
how do you motivate your players and he
said are you kidding they come in here
motivated my goal is not to demotivate
and I'm wondering within the context of
defining moments it seems to me the most
demotivation happened this work inertia
and
rather than some demotivating event and
so is your is the thinking that you can
react motivation to people who are kind
of losing steam yeah so the question is
you in many cases people come into
situations a new job a football team
motivated are is the role of defining
moments to essentially maintain that
motivation as opposed to increasing it
yeah I think it's a great question and I
think if you think about why people are
coming into that job motivated it's
because there's a moment there that
you're you're excited about the
potential to explore something new
particularly use your your hard-won
knowledge and and so I agree I think
it's a lot of cases just preventing that
from seeping away is is an important
thing and you you've done it in your
class by giving the project it's like
I'm motivated I'm motivated enough to
stay up all night and you get an
opportunity to do that yeah so I love
some of the examples in your book about
using these defining moments to actually
in creating experiences you tell a story
about I can't remember what country was
in where they were trying to influence
people's behavior related to hygiene and
that they created these experiences that
were a-ha learning experiences can you
talk a little bit about that I don't
think I can talk about that to a family
audience but how much do you believe
okay we can mark it as explicit if you
wanted to alright so for those of you
listening with your family you know what
to turn off a fast-forward past this
anecdote so the story that Tina's
referencing is a story about open
defecation so there are lots of
communities in the world that don't have
closed off toilets and it causes health
problems but they're these communities
have spent years with open defecation
and so the manipulation that they do is
an insight manipulation and there'll be
an observer that goes in and starts
walking around the village just making
notes and the kids suddenly see the
stranger and they start following around
in this
is carefully coached to be asking
questions not making statements but they
also you phrase the questions in the
most visceral provocative way so they
start saying do people always here
and people say in the kids saying yeah
yeah I said interesting did the dogs
ever do dogs ever come in this area in
and sniff the yeah they do do the
chickens ever come and eat here with the
with the and and so eventually
there'll be a crowd that forms around
this person and and the person is
trained to keep asking questions and and
they'll say for example the pluck out a
hair and dip it in a pile of and
swish it in a glass of water and say
would you drink this oh no no well how
how big is this compared to the legs of
a fly well it's smaller how many legs
are there on a fly six the flies ever
visit the and then fly in and land
on food in your house and so this
tension starts building as the community
starts being confronted by the fact that
they have for years been eating and
drinking and eventually somebody
will say that and and I think if they
questioned the person in the meantime
they're saying are you saying that we're
eating no I'm just here asking
questions I'm just recording this for a
study that we're doing and what's
powerful about that moment is is it's
not like the community doesn't know at
some level that these problems are there
they've seen your dogs playing in the
they've seen the chickens pecking
in the they seem flies going back
forth but having that crystallized
short-duration
experience with that is a powerful
moment in what this group has
successfully done is converted thousands
of communities to taking seriously the
notion of closed toilet systems it has
profound health impacts but without that
intervention the communities probably
would still be going on that decades
later I think it's I mean it was a
certainly a memorable story in the book
and you told it beautifully for those of
you tuning back in that is that is the
last of the visceral language but but
they use that that use that language
because what they're trying to do is
shock people and they're consciously
trying to give people motivation in this
case that hadn't had motivation to
change and that visceral language really
helped okay but shouldn't all educators
be experienced designers yes because
what percentage of the material that we
learn in school do we just totally
forget because we haven't been given an
experience that makes it memorable yeah
and I think that's that's a challenge
for all of us as professors and teachers
in other levels
I mean think back to your your history
how many of you can name three defining
moments where you as a kid going through
school you remember an exercise or a
lesson or a topic that a teacher took
tackle because it stands out in your
mind and then you can remember three of
those from your previous experience I'm
hoping some of my students raise their
hands all right
we're in a very distinguished for those
of you tuning in from outside we're in a
distinguished audience of 150 people and
about 20% of the people are holding up
their hands these are people that have
had access to the best educational
experiences that we deliver and my
question is why don't we have 30% why
don't we have 40% and that's why when
people are saying you know what happens
when we when we get too many of these
things I think we're so far from too
many of these things it's like all of us
deserve at least three defining moments
in our trajectory up until undergrad or
Stanford so what do we do what can we do
right here in this class to create more
defining moments in this class here's
here's one suggestion and in the
projects that you're assigning I think
you you needed to sign harder and more
rigorous in projects and make them do at
6 a.m. in the world thanks Jeff Lee but
one of the tools that we found in in
connection is there's a very interesting
social psychologist named art Aaron and
he went through a procedure he created a
procedure to BA
people and make them best of friends in
45 minutes and so you take two randomly
selected undergrads and they go into a
room and they start answering questions
and the first questions are simple that
you'd ever sing in the shower yeah I do
that you know if you could have lunch
with anybody in the world who would you
have lunch with and why and so the
questions start out easy but 15 minutes
later there's another envelope of
questions and you start drawing from
that envelope and the questions are a
little bit deeper in the third 15-minute
segment the questions are you draw a
question like if you were to die today
what would you regret not having said to
someone and why haven't you said it and
so this this two randomly selected
undergrads are going through this
process of gradually revealing more and
more of themselves and if you ask them
after 45 minutes in this exercise you
say how close do you feel to this person
that you just met 45 minutes ago and you
compare their responses on the scale to
another group of students who are asked
to rate the most powerful closest
relationship in their lives and so
people and other sampler rating their
their best friend since high school
their their mom you know their their
significant other people people that
have just met each other for forty five
minutes
score about a third of the way into the
distribution of the most powerful
relationships that people have in the
other sample and I find that remarkable
is what it says is that we're only 45
minutes away from really close
connections with lots of people in their
life
but what we never do in most situations
is take that step of getting beyond the
weather getting bound in the sports
getting beyond to something more
meaningful and so I think one of the
simplest things that you all could do to
make this class more impactful is start
with an interesting question like you
know you're here in there's so much
focus on entrepreneurship what worries
you about whether you are gonna be a
good entrepreneur or not because all
this would aspire to be that but what is
it you feel like stands in your way and
I think we had that discussion that
would start us out with closer
connections with people then when what
we normally do wonderful that's a great
suggestion
experiment with that yes what are your
peak moments in life in your academic
career after after 10 years after tenure
I started teaching right around 10-year
time a class on making ideas stick and
there was one exercise that I do at the
beginning of that class where I hand
graduate students a sample of statistics
were in the department of justice and
and have them construct a two and a half
minute speech either defending or
contradicting the idea that property
crime is a is an important problem for
the United States and so I have planned
out this exercise because I wanted to
create a defining moment for my students
and the first year I ran it and it was
beautiful so people who got together
they spent 12 minutes scripting their
their their pitch they got together and
seven people in a group made a pitch
about property crime in the United
States and then I distracted them for a
few minutes by playing a Monty Python
video and then I asked them to write
down everything they remembered about
the the speeches that they just heard
and there was this embarrassed laughter
in the crowd and all of a sudden people
realize I don't remember much of what
anybody else said and the things that
they did remember were things like
stories were things like emotional
Appeals were things like if they use
this this is the did stick it was on the
form of property crime is gonna affect
20 percent of the people in nation
whether it means an it is in a group our
size you and you might expect that in
the next five years you're gonna be
experiencing a property crime so they
make it tangible and concrete so that
was a defining moment for me because it
was an exercise that led to the eventual
publication of my first book but it was
the first time I tried that exercise in
class and it just worked so obviously
the people that they were going wow I
need a course of making ideas stick
because I just tried and I failed and
that was that was a useful exercise so
that's one defining moment I'll give you
one more we started doing course with
social entrepreneurs and in Tina and I
were talking about this this topic but
course of social
and the final day they had to present
their mission to us and what's amazing
is that even people doing really
important good work are talking about it
in a very abstract way and so one group
was talking about in in Africa they're
trying to solve the problems of up
rootedness orphan behavior by creating
community around kids that have been
dislocated by and and we listened to
that and we said you know what are you
what are you doing and they said well we
have we have a place a lot of kids in
our country wind up without parents
because AIDS and war have wiped out the
adult population and so there are kids
that will hike 100 kilometres to come be
with our group and and they said what we
believe is every child deserves a family
in a home in a community and like when
they said that people's eyes got moist
and he said why don't you take that and
put it in place of that abstract jargon
about dislocation and in orphanage you
know there there are ways that we miss
talking about even the most profound
things in the world that are simple and
concrete and that was a defining moment
for me because it was like the the the
reason we had the course was to help
people clarify their intentions and
their strategy and their mission and I
think that was a good example where we
did what we tried to do yes I have
you know I'd like you to come live about
the the landscape around these peak
moments to what degree do you select
your engineer the time and place when
you can create these defining moments
for people the anniversary of their
birth or the first day of their jobs
break me as being moments that already
have some expectations built into them I
I have been in the habit for a while
asking people but the best meal of their
life has been and I discovered that's
always just another way of asking the
question when were they hungriest
wondering if you can build a mountain
more easily on a plane than in a
mountain range it's a great question and
I suspect that there are some people
there are some people that we might not
want to work for who are specialists in
in in turning up the temperature and
making things difficult enough that when
a breakthrough happens we feel really
good about that and so one of the
characteristics when people in business
schools teach power and politics and
they have the feature characters like
Lyndon Baines Johnson or Steve Jobs one
of the things that people always say
about these individuals is they can make
you feel so awful about yourself and
what you've done but they can make you
feel so good about what what you've done
and I think that that discrepancy
you know if I'm down here and then all
of a sudden they do something right and
Steve Jobs praises me I think that
discrepancy sometimes make makes leaders
more powerful I'm not gonna recommend
those tactics but like I like what
you're what you're observing is that the
best meal in the world is probably the
time when we were most hungry
do I want to engineer hunger no but I do
want to say if you're trying to bond a
group of people you may want to create a
boot camp kind of environment where
people are doing something difficult
that is meaningful and important and if
they do the all-nighter that in Tina's
class I think they're going to be more
more happy about the eventual bonding
experience of I think having achieved
that yes insights about the difference
between
peak moments that you're sort of
cognizant of as they're happening versus
the things that only in retrospect come
stand out in question so question is do
you understand peaks at the time or some
are only clear in retrospect when we
survey people about that it's about
50/50 and we haven't we haven't figured
out what makes the 5050 but I think a
lot of times the insights to take a
while to percolate and so we realized in
retrospect that was that was a turning
point for us that took us in a
productive direction but we didn't
realize it at the time but it's a great
great question
so I have an idea I think we should use
the last three minutes of this class to
create a defining moment okay and what
I'm thinking is we will thank you
profoundly for your talk and inspiring
us and creating this defining moment but
I'm thinking what we should do is have
everybody stand up and talk to someone
they don't know and to ask them what
they're looking forward to and make a
real connection with someone new what do
you think should we do that I think I
want to I want to up the ante a little
bit ask him ask him what worries worries
themselves the most about about being in
Silicon Valley okay
maybe maybe we could do both what are
you excited about it what are you most
concerned about beautiful okay great
let's thank our wonderful guests thank
you chip
[Applause]
you